quelle soirée incroyable
de voir qu'on est si nombreux et
nombreuses ce soir
j'ai adoré le film
de King Lear aussi vraiment au top
Javier et sa femme les deux sont nommés
ce soir
lui il ne peut pas gagner
il est en train de prier que c'est Will
Smith qui va gagner et pas lui
de voir la suite du film
non mais c'était une petite vannerie
pour elle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je veux plus entendre un mot de ta
bouche
alors c'était une blague
ne parle pas de ma femme ok promis OK
ça c'était
la plus grande soirée de la l'histoire
de la télévision
ok alors nous sommes ici
pour
remettre un Oscar au meilleur
documentaire
alors la beauté des documentaires il
vous permet de vous sentir intelligent
comme si vous aviez lu un livre
mais en fait tout ce qu'on a fait c'est
fumer un joint regarder Netflix alors on
va regarder ça de plus près